dans un an jour pour jour donald et
mickey ouvriront leurs portes au public
à marne-la-vallée un an de cet événement
euro disney a accueilli journalistes et
caméras pour une visite de chantier
une visite vous allez voir mener à
l'américaine reportage huguette et
claude du sud
les américains aiment les dates symbole
euro disney ouvre ses portes dans un an
jour pour jour les organisateurs ont
tenu à ce que ça se sache
résultat une journée où rien n'a été
laissé au hasard journalistes escorté
par les casses même aux miches à pont ni
hôtesses bottes et casque pour tous
fanfare à l'américaine et en prime la
présence du neveu de walt disney roj
disney bref une organisation à l'image
de ce chantier de 2000 hectares
démesurée quelques chiffres pour mesurer
l'ampleur du projet plus de 180
entreprises
cinq mille trois cents ouvriers français
espagnol italien allemand qui travaille
sans relâche pas question de transiger
sur la date d'ouverture
une soixantaine l'embauchent par semaine
à terme euro disney devrait employer
douze mille personnes
plus de 5000 chambres réparties sur six
hôtels disneyland hôtel séquoia lodge
cheyenne hôtels et cetera construction
d'une ligne directe rer et d'une gare
tgv
bref de quoi accueillir 11 millions de
visiteurs venus de tous les pays
d'europe
un dernier chiffre l'investissement se
monte à 55 milliards mirapolis et le
parc d'astérix ne joue pas dans la même
cour trente cinq ans que nous exerçons
chez on al'avantage énorme d'avoir
hérité de tous ces personnages peuvent
désirer quand mickey c'est connu vient
seulement en europe et dans le monde
ce quatrième monde enchanté de disney
difficile encore de l'imaginer
aujourd'hui pour un adulte en tout cas
car pour un enfant une marionnette
suffit